l'appareil de golgi la chose fascinante
dans tout ceci
c'est qu'alex true love va faire l'amour
la semaine prochaine un chaleur suaire
telle est la vraie recette d'un rapport
sexuel réussi où tu m'appelles alex
frolov et oui c'est mon vrai nom j'ai
une très bonne moyenne générale on m'a
élu président de lycée et j'ai une super
copine tu viens avec nous à la fête
alors maintenant tu te sort les doigts
du cul et tu viens avec moi assieds toi
avec les seuls gens cool ici je crois
qu'on va débaucher alex sinon j'ai une
copine wii et super mignonne c'est vrai
j'ai rencontré un mec j'ai l'impression
que je lui plais et disons que je suis
pas complètement contre l'idée écoute je
sais pas ce qu'ils ont les gens
si tu regardes et ils sont tous soumis
sexuel ou en transition
comment tu as su que j'étais gay comment
tu sais tu es des eaux
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce qu'il ya ça fait huit mois que
je fais tout pour t'aider puces mais
visiblement je me prends mal c'est
devenu mad max adam des mecs qui savent
des mecs v9 avec des meufs défi qui
viennent des mecs qui nique des filles
qui couche avec des pays et des mecs
ras le cul tout ça sex mour ça me saoule
est ce que quelqu'un pourrait
m'expliquer comment fonctionnent les
garçons terminent
quoi tu as peur
c'est étrange
[Musique]
zhu